hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it's the
finals of the fide grand prix are
currently being played in belgrade this
is the second leg of the grand prix uh
the third one will be played in some
eight to nine days in uh in berlin yeah
it's richard rapper versus dimitri
andreikin and this is their second game
of the match so first classical game
ended in a draw we didn't show that when
it was incredibly short and it ended
like in maybe half an hour maybe an hour
i i don't know about it like uh
it uh it was over before i even uh
started watching the the coverage uh but
the second game is a bit more
interesting and it really shows you what
kind of a fighter you have to be in
order to not maybe just win a grand prix
but also maybe qualify for the
candidates tournament so let's see uh
what happened here upper with the white
pieces opens with d4 uh we have d5
bandwagon c for e6 knight to c3 and now
usually knight to f6 is pretty much uh
an automatic here okay there are a lot
of games where bishop a7 can be played
you can play many other moves here you
could play bishop to b4 here but uh here
we have a6 and this is somewhat rare
this is the yanovsky variation and it
comes very early on this a6 move so how
uh how does white meet this well of
course c captures on d5 this is the
standard way and everyone knows this
that's how you play against the the
janovski variation e captures on d5 and
although it's very rare for example
magnus had this position on the board uh
with uh both white and black pieces um
uh but even more with the black pieces
he had it uh many many times and he
defeated some very strong players so
with this he defeated darunyan he
defeated
i think
nakamura or maybe it was a draw against
nakamura i know he defeated arunyan and
he had it like against rajabov he had
against nakamura against the ding
against wesley uh so it's it is
people don't play it a lot but magnus
for example likes it very much uh and
usually white will continue with some
like knight to f3 also bishop to f4 is
an idea some sort of um uh well uh
london londonish system setup but here
rapport says i'm not uh playing any of
this that you've prepared i'm going to
play a3 and this is now
very very tricky and not a lot of games
with this exact move order or rather if
you only count uh top level games it's
already as of move five that we have a
completely new game so here andreikin
says all right uh two can play that game
or rather three and he plays h6 now
saying uh would you play now
so first rapport avoids andreikin's
preparation and now uh andre can sort of
uh avoid that upwards counter
preparation uh so what do you play here
it's basically a challenge will rapport
play h3 or not and this would be
completely crazy but of course he
doesn't he plays bishop to f4 he
continues in his uh in his setup knight
to f6 and now e3 we have c5 now
challenging the center and now the early
bishop to e5 and this will be this will
be very very exciting as you'll see
so if black just continues with let's
say knight to c6 puts pressure on the
bishop here uh white gladly captures
because now if the queen captures an f6
the d5 pawn is hanging so black will
have to ruin his pawn structure so uh
here on rayquen defends the d5 pawn
plays bishop to e6 now comes knight g to
e2 continuing development now we have
knight to c6 and just knight to f4
saying okay you're welcome to capture on
e5 but i will have all this incredible
pressure against your pawn for example
if captures capture knight is hanging
and also if you move it then you removed
one of the defenders of the d5 pawn
and white will just win this game very
early so instead after knight to f4 we
have c captures on d4 bishop captures on
the for now and now black wins the
bishop knight captures on the e4 queen
captures on the e4 so white has a
beautifully developed queen as there is
no knight here to kick it away from
there and now bishop to d6 so nicely
continuing development we have g3
again the rapport tries to make the game
very sharp because if black ever
captures on f4 then white would get the
semi-open h g file and that's not
something you want to give white and
also you have the bishop pair you you
kind of want something more to to give
it up so here after this g3 move we have
rooked the c8 continuing development and
now rook to d1 putting even more
pressure on that d5 pawn so queen to a5
pinning the knight and also adding
another defender to the d5 pawn and now
uh here rapper plays rook back to c1
it's hard to
understand why play rook to d1 and then
rook to c1 probably if something like
queen the c5 comes offering a queen
trade then you can move the queen defend
the rook and maybe then you will have
some nice discoveries with the with the
knight but still it's a very very
uh
uh difficult to realize why this is
played or not just for example continued
development uh but okay here on the king
castles and now we have knight captures
on e6 uh and this is why i thought it
was strange as this knight captures an
e6 idea can be played with rook on d1 it
doesn't really change all that much so
here we have f captures and e6 and
bishop to h3 now threatening to pick up
the pawn of course you cannot advance it
uh you could as it comes with an attack
on the queen but um
it wouldn't really it wouldn't really
work if you play e5 here then we just
move the queen queen d5 uh queen d1
queen d3 or wherever and now these pawns
are very very weak and the black will
have a hard time uh keeping on to the to
the position so instead after bishop to
h3 king the f7 this is a very nice way
of doing things saying that my king is
perfectly fine defending the pawn and
now my rook can enter the game so
rockford castles and now rook to c4
now andreikin will also be able to
double rooks on the c file and robert
has to move the queen so queen to d3 now
comes bishop to e5 adding another defen
attacker to the c3 pawn maybe rapper saw
all the way to here and he thought okay
maybe the rook will uh help out with the
defense of the c3 knight very nicely uh
so now knight's the e2 offering a rook
trade and andre king just uh doubles on
the c file yeah it puts a lot of
pressure here so it
trades once we have captures captures
and now uh this is a very uh interesting
position how do you continue here one
way is the start with f4 that's the only
way for pretty much for white to seek
advantage
and the other one is uh do something
about the b2 pawn that's hanging so i
will just show what happens if the
immediate f4 is played
then black and capture on b2 very safely
and you play rook to b1 saying okay now
if you move the bishop i'm going to
capture on b7 with check then maybe pick
up d6 pawn this will be very good for me
but black will just capture on a3 offer
a queen trade and after queens get
traded off let's root capture some b7
check now uh not only e6 but also g7
will be hanging and now after black
makes a move we can capture either of
the pawns for example captures on g7 but
then bishop c5 and black will also have
some pressure and it's hard to say if
white does really gain anything from
this as it's black with the outside pass
pawn
so maybe
not to everyone's liking so instead
first we have b4 rapport takes care of
that and uh well also that's a very
important move to play queen to a4 and
now only now uh not f4 if you go f4 now
then bishop to b2 is again very strong
so you haven't really accomplished
anything
knights to f4 now putting pressure on
the e6 pawn and now black has to give up
the bishop for the knight so bishop
captures an f4 e captures an f4 and now
queen to c6 saying that okay what are
you going to do now i can harass your
queen i can put the rook on e4 i can put
the knight on e4 i can play rook to c1
right away to trade off a pair of rooks
so how do you push for anything here
with white it would seem that uh
andre can defend it very well and that
he is now ready to call it a day and
then everything will be settled tomorrow
in rapid tie breaks so here queen to e3
by richard and now knight to e4 the
knight is excellently placed here and
it's not going to be
possible to kick it away from there
unless you play something like f3 which
weakens your king but this is exactly
what rapper does so uh here uh andreikin
doesn't move the knight that would be
very risky but first rook to c3
challenges the queen queen to d4 and now
rook to c4 he's ready to call it a day
and uh and try his luck tomorrow in the
rapid tie bricks uh queen to e3 rook to
c3 queen to d4 and rook to c4 and if
rapper repeats once again then it's
going to be a draw by by threefold
repetition however rapper went into a
deep thing not too deep of a thing as
they were both very low on time uh below
below the 20 minute mark uh so uh he
spent some of his time and played queen
to e5 and this is now incredibly
dangerous as
black is uh going to play knight to d to
put pressure on on on white king side
the the rook and queen are all ready to
jump into the position so what is uh he
gaining by this queen to e5 well he
wants to get this f5 move in and bust
open the position here however this will
cost him some material so knight to d2
andre can play this pretty much
instantly and now f5 so can he gain
something from this uh what are black's
options here well the only two real
options are knight captures on f1
because if we don't grab the material
then we've simply allowed white to have
a free attack
or to throw in a nice queen to b6 check
now this is very important so we are
going to discuss the queen to b6 check
uh this was not played but uh it kind of
forces a draw because after king to h1
we're going to capture them at the rook
now and after f captures on e6 we're
going to play king the g8 this is very
important and now after queen to b8
check we're going to play king to h7
bishop to f5 check g6 attacking the
bishop and now e7 or some other moves
like bishop captures and g6 are also
possible i'm just showing you the at the
most fun uh draw drawish lines and after
e7 preparing to bring another queen into
the game we can play rook to c1 threaten
some very nasty discoveries here so
white will have to play everything very
very quickly he has to give up the queen
uh but only temporarily king captures
now we're gonna bring another queen in
with check and after the king moves
queen to f7 check and this will now be a
draw by a repetition pretty much because
the queen covers the g6 square you will
be unable to capture here and deliver
checkmate so after this we'll see
something like a repetition here so this
is what would happen most likely if uh
queen the b6 check is played but
andreikin says nope that's not necessary
i want to keep my queen and rook on the
c file i'm going to play knight captures
on f1 which is perfectly fine unless uh
you you know uh mess it up uh so here
are apple continues of course with f
captures and e6 with check and now what
do you play here this is the position
feel free to pause the video and try not
to blunder the game uh with the black
pieces for andreikin while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on playing a move no
one plays in this position and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is king to e7 that's the only move
that uh that
allows black to stay in the game uh if
you try king the g8 that we tried in the
in the previous line then queen then
ponte e7 and how are you how are you
getting out of this there's really not
much you can try here uh if if you go
with king to f7 then there's a bishop to
f5 very deadly
and now uh you your knight is simply in
the way of your pieces if you try
something like rook to e1 there's a
bishop the g6 check kicking the king
away from the defense of the of the
queening square and that's it we're just
going to bring the queen into the game
you're going to have to capture here and
this is now of course a winning position
for white white has a queen black
doesn't so that's what happens if you if
you play king to jade like in the line
that we've discussed here of course you
could try something else uh but um uh
well okay we'll show king to e7 because
this is the only move that draws point
is that after queen to g7 check and this
is something draken of course wanted to
avoid if he has to give up the g7 point
he would rather it doesn't come with
check now you're gonna go to d6 and
after queen to f8 check came to c7 you
push e7 but now you have queen to b6
check king captures on f1 uh and uh or
or you go to go to h1 and then we simply
uh move the knight with temple with
check and then we have rook to c1 so
king captures an f1 rook c1 check and
now after king to e2 queen b5 check and
after king to d2 there's rook to c to
check this is how we get our queen in
and now you either get checkmated or you
take the rook and then queen to e to
check will allow black to have um
a draw by perpetual because the the
white queen is nowhere near uh around
the to help the white king and after you
make some moves let's king b3 we can
just play queen d3 check you can't go up
the board because b5 check will end in
checkmate so you have to go down the
board and then we can use these squares
to continue checking the white king and
that's all we need basically so that's
why king the e7 after this uh crazy move
uh is enough for andreikin to draw the
game however he played king to e8 and
this is a little bit different because
now uh rapper plays queen captures on g7
and how do you continue this well again
uh many options uh queen the b6 check
was played which is kind of similar at
the the previous line but now after king
captures an f1 notice that the white
queen is still on g7 and that's a huge
difference
we have rook to c1 with check king to e2
and now how do you defend now one way is
to go back for example rook to c7 you
try and defend checkmate because even if
you're trying to do something to the
white king white will easily checkmate
your own king so if you try something
like this queen to g6 check let's say k7
queen to f7 checking d6 queen f6 check
now trying to
push the pawn with check rook to a7
blocking now we're to play f4 f5 and
it's just going to be an unplayable
position for black let's say queen to d8
we're gonna play queen e5 check once the
king moves f5 is coming f6 is coming and
that's resigns for black so instead
andre can try rook to e1 with check it's
similar to what we discussed you have to
give up the rook to again get the
perpetual however there is a huge
problem here uh king captures on e1 and
now queen the e3 with check and now the
problem is uh the queen is on this
diagonal that's but that's only one of
his uh problems usually that is not
enough for uh for uh one of the players
to deny you this particular perpetual
idea uh but also there's the bishop on
h3 and it doesn't seem like the bishop
here is included in anything however uh
it uh it is here we have king to d1 uh
and this is the only way for you to for
you to actually win this game if you try
king to f1 then queen to c1 check and
then black will most certainly have his
perpetual because now black has all the
squares needed
to continue checking you uh to continue
checking you here uh so instead king to
d1 was played and it seems like yes you
will again have all the squares but not
really because now queen d3 check king
to c1 queen to e3 check king to b1 queen
to d3 check king to c1 here rapper
repeats once the
to get to move 40 to be awarded
additional time queen to e3 check now
king b2 and now queen to d to check here
we have king the a1 and now queen to c1
with check we have king the a2 and now
if you uh check the king uh improperly
then we can block check with queen to b2
but even this is not a problem uh just
to give you an example if uh queen to c2
we're going to block with queen to b2
queen to c4 check now comes king to a1
and you can see that the real problem is
in the bishop on h3 because if you could
use this diagonal uh to deliver checks
with uh queen on c4 and queen on f1 then
black would have no choice but to
uh but to block uh uh well i'd either
sidestep or block with the queen
but it would not be enough uh here of
course andreikin did not try this he
played queen to c for which check but
now comes king b2 queen to e to check
now again you have to keep using this
diagonal
king a1 and now uh unfortunately for
andreikin there is no queen to f1 check
of course if you try some other check
like queen to d1 then you will no longer
have the uh c for dc for square uh you
you will be unable to reach the c4
square and if you check the king via the
second rank then of course you will
allow the white queen to come back into
the defense so here andreikin wanted to
fully uh appreciated the power of the
bishop on h3 so he played queen to f1
check it is the move from the thumbnail
to show everyone why the idea doesn't
work and why it would usually work it's
just that that bishop on h3 is what
prevents the uh the whole plan from
working so here rapper captured the
queen with bishop captures on f1 and he
was in this position i know 46 that
dimitri andreikin resigned in the game
which means that rapport wins the second
pa second leg of the grand prix and
these are the current standings of the
grand prix here is a nice um
uh sorry i thought i
thought i had it loaded uh here is a
nice uh graphic from from chess24
uh so you can see that that upward is
currently leading after two grand prix
he has 20 grand three points which means
he's uh currently uh well the the the
most likely candidate to qualify for the
next feed a candidate's tournament uh
and here you have with um uh 13 points
he karuna kimura and with 10 uh lavon
and dmitry and raikkin the problem is uh
well not for rapper that's great for
rapper that uh levon and dimitri will be
in the same uh in the same group uh in
the third leg of the grand prix that
starts in eight days in um in berlin uh
and it's uh well almost almost sure that
rapport has qualified for the key in the
video candidates tournament uh if you if
you trust the numbers there is a six
percent chance that he doesn't qualify
but that's in a
you know very very uh unlikely scenario
that no one believes that could actually
happen but if it's uh you know even
possible then of course it could happen
so he is not in the candidates yet
but he is very close to qualifying
basically he's done all he could and
it's better that he
won today in a classical clash uh rather
than tomorrow in a rapid as you get more
points for for a win in the classical so
this is uh this is the best as he could
have possibly done so big
congratulations to rapport uh we'll see
uh what happens it would be it would be
very very interesting to have him in the
candidates tournament as he's playing
some real fighting chess no quick draws
no okay yesterday was a quick draw but
here he had the white pieces and he
could have drawn that and then take it
into tie breaks but he didn't he
uh well it's hard to say if he
calculated everything but he calculated
enough to you know allow himself to to
indulge in this great risk which in the
end
uh proved favorable for him uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh really really
awesome showing and what what uh you
know great sportsmanship from from
andreikin uh you know finishing the game
like this just queen to f1 i mean
no one does this so it was a
definitely a very gentlemanly move uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and this entire coverage of
the of the second leg of the video grand
prix uh i would like to thank uh max
dorovski francis ayer geoffrey munster
abdul rahman el omari and draw all more
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day